you talked a little bit about the source
material because whit stillman
discovered it not a lot of people have
heard about it and what does it give you
just as the building blocks for this
character well when I was first sent the
script it was such an outrageous script
I kept kind of flipping back to the
title page going hey wit has written
something in the style of jana not
actually based on a Jane Austen book
that I've never heard of you know and
and but he really had and so going back
to the novella it's it's even darker
than at the end she as a character is
even darker and kind of more ruthless
and very very mean to her daughter in
the in the novella which is still really
funny but only partially me in the movie
just partially yeah yeah a little
sidebar mean to the daughter but I don't
know I really liked the the novella I
mean I it's a wonderful thing to have
this kind of extra reading to do you
know as an actor and and she's a I spent
I mean it's really fun support but I
suppose I think to myself you know that
the central part of this part for me was
the conversation with her daughter where
she's saying you know we visit we you've
got to sort out your security through
how are you going to live if you don't
find a husband because underpinning all
of her behavior really is its it she's
very much a product of the time period
that she's in and certainly for a woman
at that time especially if you were a
bright you know intellectually sharp
woman who remotely was interested in
having kind of any kind of sexual
freedom or you know any kind of freedom
really education I think you've had to
box a little bit clever and obviously
Jane Austen was a great mind in that you
know not of that and lived under these
kind of rigorous social rules and I
suppose fancifully I think of Lady Susan
as being sort of her shadow that she you
know in age 20 kind of sort of expressed
her frustration with the the situation
that she was in and then kind of went oh
that's a bit much and put it in a drawer
and you know it wasn't till 40 or 50
years after she died that her nephew
published it I think we're describing is
a 21st century woman who happened to be
born in the 18th century
exactly exactly what would she be like
today which would be running a fortune
500 she'd have a very nice job 7 if you
lovers nobody say anything you know
daughter be at boarding school and Ivy
care one of the tricks of the story and
the tricks of the film and the tricks of
the
character is that she is both kind of
heroine and villainous and asks your
first kind of talking to wit about the
making of this movie what kinds of
conversations are you having around that
balance about which way it should go
which way it's written and where you
find the balance between the two because
she is in many ways a very likable
person that you end up loving to dislike
have you met wit yes okay so there
wasn't really they sort of conversations
I think the thing about wit and I find
him very similar to Scorsese in that
respect is that I think he you know he
bruised and percolates from an
extraordinarily long time I mean he went
subterranean for at least what 10 years
or so that I think is been working on
this for at least I want yeah so there's
been a quite the gestation so I think by
the time he actually casts people he's
picked somebody whose sensibility is
likely to match his own so that he
doesn't have to have those sort of
conversations really you know he's a
very elegant person all around and so I
think it would almost feel peculiar to
be saying you know do you think he'll to
be likeable or not I think he'd be so
repulsed by that conversation I can't
imagine having it but I think I think
the fact that obviously I responded soma
I mean I loved this character so much
and it was a sort of unsaid thing that
we both I think felt the same way and
and we had a you know quite an
epistolary relationship before shooting
because he asked me to give my notes on
the script which I always find amazing
when it's somebody who's writing the
script tends to be kind of much more
open to other people's opinion open it
found that with writer directors tend to
be a bit more kind of free with with
that and it was Christmas and my mum was
coming and there was all sorts of chaos
and they kept saying oh I can't do you
know because if you up and asked me to
do notes I went to Oxford I want to do
something notes ready yeah I'm not gonna
write a couple of things on a post-it
like I'll do my homework so I kept
saying away I can I do it after
Christmas and he kept saying please
don't have them I really want them I'm
doing another draft and so then I sent
this kind of gigantic epic long email
which he managed to not seem too
offended by him and then we went back
and forth like that for quite awhile you
know with Mika we'd sort of mining the
novel and also you know because there
are so many different characters and
different names and you kind of need to
know what the range it's all very early
I loved how he fixed that in terms of
there
productions yes it can be a little bit
confusing in the in the novella even
going who and earth are these people and
you know some of them have the same last
name I don't understand the relationship
and all that so there was some kind of
clarity things and there's some kind of
greedy things of going can we put this
back in and all they're so yeah so I
think by the time we turned up here he's
not somebody who does a lot of rehearsal
or anything so we'd had this kind of you
know rather old-fashioned epistolary
which is which is a fancy word for
letters or emails I guess yes when you
were to go back and look at what you're
writing him and the kinds of concerns or
the kinds of conversations that you're
having
what were they were they around a
certain theme where there's a certain
idea that you kept hammering about that
you were really focused on in terms of
this character was it a broader story
brought her interest broader questions
that you were pursuing I know if some of
it was just sort of in terms of clarity
and character and stuff like that and
some of it was really oh my god there's
some really delicious stuff that we
can't we put back in you know and and
you know we could have made three movies
given that in the novella is short and
unfinished and yet it's kind of
jam-packed full of you know amazing
terrible things that this person is
saying and doing say I want to talk
about the physical production of this
film and it's something that I suspect
was very important I hope in finding
character and that is costume design and
your fittings and working with a costume
designer are you an actor who finds you
can help discover character especially
in a period film through wardrobe and if
so how did this help you figure out this
character I mean especially in a paired
film it's always you know the underwear
is terribly telling came here tell me
more well it really kind of affects how
you stand how you sit how fast you can
move around you know how you speak all
of that stuff having a really serious
corset on is you know rather an
impediment to rushing up the stairs or
whatever but yeah wit and I in a you
know grand romance and of letters had
talked a lot about wanting Lady Susan to
start in kind of widow's weeds and black
and then sort of ease out into a sort of
move and then just rushed right into you
know harlots ready go for the morning
wardrobe yeah exactly and I really liked
that and whit's very wit was very into
veils and he liked the idea of there
being kind of veils and all that in the
beginning but I you know I've done a lot
of period movies in England and so
I've done you know varying types of
budget and I was expecting what very
often happens cuz we have wonderful
costume houses in England I was
expecting that you know you're wearing
Kate Winslet's dress from something and
somebody else's dress with something
else and that you know better often
happens and did you very well about it
but with this quite modest budget I was
astonished by the fact that the costume
designer Emma would have made pretty
much all Chloe and my clothes from
scratch and so you know you were to come
to work and they'd there'd be a kind of
a complete cause of Christmas present in
your trailer of this kind of complete
outfit with hats and gloves and shoes
and I didn't know how they did it to
this day don't know how they did it but
but it was a really big endeavor you
have incredible rich incredibly rich
dialogue in this film and yet I think
you just said you didn't have a lot of
time for rehearsal
so how do you get as an actor to wrap
your tongue around this dialogue and and
present in a way that works in concert
with the other actors I'm not frightened
of dad I love a bit of dialogue me but
the thing that was worrying and one of
the one of the things that I kept asking
him in the weeks leading up to shooting
was will there be a final draft of the
script so that I can let it like when
you do a play you know if you're going
to play King Lear quite often get some
of the learning out of the way before
you turn up and that was I was planning
on doing because we had you know we I
think we've been allowed 27 days to
shoot the movie which is not a lot
considering how verbose my character in
particular is and he was quite cagey
about that and shady and what I'd
forgotten in the 18 years in which I had
not worked with which is that you know
he's amazingly well prepared and
obviously he writes his own scripts um
the other big strength of his is that
he's incredibly responsive to the moment
which cannot mean that you're sitting in
hair and makeup having spent all of last
night learning pages and pages of
dialogue only to find that he switched
them all around all the bit you know
different parts of the speech around and
then has added something else completely
different about Connecticut or something
and just sort of expects you to you know
say it and you know I felt like I was
having some kind of you know
preventative Alzheimer's workout
the equivalent of doing Doku yeah so
I'll be furious if I do end up getting
it actually I got my money back
but yeah so that was that was a
contention so really you know as well
because the schedule was so short you
know you don't want to be that person
who you know the costume designer is
pull these costumes out of nowhere we've
got these amazing country house it's
everyone's on their game and then you
know Kate's forgotten her lines it just
couldn't happen so I think I was awake
most of the 27 days watching the movie
it's almost like watching a play and
that wit has cast incredibly talented
actors who are razor-sharp with dialogue
and they come from a very you know broad
spectrum of backgrounds can you talk a
little bit about the ensemble and
especially maybe your daughter and the
kinds of scenes that you were able to
share together and what the creative
partnership was like and how much
freedom you had even though wit is very
precise about what his films are gonna
look like and sound like what kind of
freedom you had as actors within those
parameters to may be depart and maybe
find something that was new and
different I mean it was like I said it
was an odd one because it was such a
short shoot so really there was no kind
of there was no sort of overspill and
her kind of people doing wild drunken
evenings and you know I think everyone
was so busy rushing home and learning
their lines it wasn't the most kind of
social you know movie but I do remember
the read-through where pretty much
everyone turned up except for Tom
Bennett who was shooting something else
and very often if an actor can't be
there and has to be beamed in by Skype
it creates a kind of scrim between you
and them to where it just doesn't film
anyway it was he'd showed up with this
complete performance almost exactly like
that to everyone's astonishment and
derailed the read-through immediately I
mean we were all falling but let me know
it was really funny and really even more
extraordinary considering he wasn't even
physically there and it was at you know
on a computer screen it was brilliant so
that was wonderful I think that I think
we really like that and consequently wit
wrote more scenes he I think he got very
inspired by commitments more come on
with exactly exactly and also I think
because you know he'd he'd he'd not he'd
not expected to find an actor who can
make how are you
you know that's kind of a big thing I
think width:auto you know what person
fairly boring dialogue here holy [ __ ] do
you know this guy's killing it you know
say he so he hit that the peas actually
were written while we were shooting the
whole peas thing which was wonderful and
so you know that that was lovely and
then you know everybody was one but I
loved my daughter that was the only hard
thing was she was so sweet and Welsh and
just talented and lovely and you know
having to be so rotten to her all the
time it's quite difficult but I was also
you know mainly her either learning
lines furiously in a panic or a sweat or
changing costumes which is no small feat
in itself because it takes a bit of a
while and everybody's going all hurry up
you know so I felt like a little bit
sorta better removed from the kind of
the gang because I always was talking
more than everybody else or changing
clothes more than everybody else and I
remember the dance sequence think the
dance scene I've suddenly to my horror
realized that other people had had the
odd free afternoon to go into a dance
rehearsal and I was told we were doing
this today and there was no time say
there's horrible
everybody sort of hopping it's sort of a
hoppy dancing loris of hopping in the
right direction then of course I had
completely hot left and ruin it and so
again say I felt I felt very clumsy in
that scene Kate Beckinsale thank you so
much thank you guys for coming out